[Music]
back in April 2020 I decided to make a
video that unbeknownst to me would
change the course of my channel forever
a valiant quest to take the scrambled
2019 reveal teaser for bre the wild 2
now known as tears of the kingdom and
try to piece together a chronological
order of events as well as a General
story Direction it is to this day one of
my best performing videos I've ever made
and the reception I got back then was
beyond anything I could have imagined so
did my predictions end up being correct
no not really no but in hindsight I
think it's safe to say that it was an
impossible task to begin with a lot can
change in 4 years and while I wouldn't
call it unrecognizable it is clear that
the 2019 footage was a lot more
conceptual than many of us had perhaps
anticipated of course it's not unusual
for a Zelda game or any game for that
matter to go through some major changes
during its development cycle especially
when it comes to early promotional
material I mean just look at breath wild
reveal as a somewhat recent example not
only does Hy ru's layout look
considerably different from the one we
actually ended up exploring but that
whole sequence of Link being chased by a
guardian ended up being nothing more
than a proof of concept A pre-rendered
cinematic that establishes a general
setting and atmosphere to get people
excited but does not actually show up in
the game itself now in the case of Tears
of the Kingdom the differences between
the early promotion and the final game
aren't nearly as drastic which does make
sense not only did it have the luxury of
reusing the same engine and assets but
the game as a whole was born from
leftover ideas for DLC and so the Zelda
team likely had a better sense of
direction from the get-go compared to
its predecessor despite all the
differences between the teaser footage
and the opening segment seen in the
final game you can tell that a lot of
the core ingredients were already there
back in 2019 the return of Ganondorf the
zonai connections Link's magic arm the
rising High Castle even the idea that
something bad was going to happen to
Princess Zelda Looking Back Now it's
pretty interesting to see how these
early Concepts have changed since that's
why for today's video I thought it would
be fun to revisit the 2019 teaser and
see how it compares to the final product
we'll cover the most notable differences
theorize why they could have been
changed and see if there's any traces of
these early Concepts left in the game
itself to make things a bit more
interesting we're also going to create a
new version of the 2019 teaser using
only footage and assets from tear of the
Kingdom's final build a teaser remake if
you will this means we're going to
tackle every shot from the teaser in
order of appearance and see if we can
find a suitable replacement for each one
and of course at the very end I'm going
to present to you the final result so
without further Ado let's jump right
into
[Music]
it to start off I want to quickly point
out that some of the shots from tears of
the Kingdom's promotional material were
obviously made for cinematic purposes
and were never meant to be part of the
game to begin with these these types of
shots were custom made and staged by
Nintendo just to get a more exciting
view of the action they also did this in
more recent trailers like for example
this sequence right here never shows up
in the final game either it's simply a
shot of Link skydiving without any Hut
elements visible and using a custom
camera placement which isn't achievable
in the game under normal circumstances
as such I think it's only fair that for
the creation of our own teaser I will be
allowed to use custom camera angles of
my own after all some of the shots from
the 2019 teaser simply don't exist in
tear of the Kingdom but by using a free
cam we have a bit more control of the
action and sometimes we can get a pretty
close match so let's get started the
teaser kicks off with a closeup of the
green zone ey particles which constantly
change shape and morph into various
symbols or glyphs now these particles or
zonai glyphs usually don't look or
behave like this in the game itself in
most cases they are simplified 2D
Sprites with some kind of wavy effect
thrown on top just to give the illusion
of movement likely to save up a memory
that's said the original animation did
survive and has been reused for the
title screen you can even match up some
of the particles and see that the way
they move is close to identical so it's
likely the same animation they made back
in 2019 I initially thought this effect
was just a pre-render 2d overlay or
something but as it turns out these
particles are actually full 3d and are
likely running in engine which is pretty
awesome but it does make recreating the
2019 shot a bit more difficult since for
technical Reasons I'm not going to bore
you with you cannot simply extract a
particle system from The Game's files
like you would do any conventional 3D
object which I have done plenty of times
in the past besides that the particles
keep resetting and jump all over the
place as the title sequence plays out
which normally you don't see because the
camera moves and change positions with
it but when you view it from a static
angle you can see what I mean so for
this shot I had to resort to some After
Effects trickery I used a reverse green
screen effect to isolate the particles
from my recordings captured some green
mist from inside one of the shrines to
use as a backdrop added some blur and
camera movement and there you go it's
not perfect by any means but it's
workable going back to the teaser we
then fade into an establishing shot of
the imprisoning chamber with Ganondorf
sealed corpse and the green spiraling
energy as the main focal point overall
the imprisoning chamber still looks
pretty similar in tears of the Kingdom
the platform in the middle the spikes
protruding from the walls the
pyramid-like structure on the ceiling
it's all still here the differences
mostly lie in the smaller details the
platform or alter Ganondorf stands on
used to look more like a natural rock
formation but in the final build it's a
circular man-made structure the spikes
on the walls now have Zoni writings on
them as opposed to the white paint-like
decorations seen in the teaser and the
pyramid on the ceiling also received a
bit of an overhaul in terms of its
design and shape but that's about the
extent of it in general I do think the
room looks better in the final build it
maintains the dark and creepy atmosphere
from the teaser while at the same time
adding that little extra detail to make
it look less like a natural cave and
more like a place that was constu
constructed for a specific purpose the
only thing that's unfortunate is that
the imprisoning chamber cannot be
explored properly in game at least not
until Ganondorf has been set free at
which point most of the room's
architecture has completely collapsed
luckily we can get a much better view of
the layout using the free cam for
example the staircase and Bridge leading
to the altar which were not visible in
the teaser and are barely visible during
gameplay because of the limited view and
the lighting also worth noting is that
there's two pieces of concept art for
this room in the art book one of The End
Rance and stairway and one of the alter
Ganondorf stands on as you can see the
alter already looks more like the one we
see in game as opposed to the one from
the teaser meaning the teaser was almost
certainly created before the concept art
as opposed to the other way around as
for trying to recreate this moment there
is an establishing shot in the opening
sequence that looks somewhat similar to
the one from the teaser however
unfortunately the camera remains static
for only about a second or two and then
moves backwards to reveal linkoln Zelda
which is not going to work unless I slow
it down down since the original shot is
about 5 Seconds long so instead I just
use the free cam to make my own custom
shot and get used to me saying that next
we cut to a closeup of Zelda's torch
which illuminates a cave painting of
Ganondorf on Horseback and I think it's
safe to say that these paintings are
likely the precursor to the mural that
depicts the history of the imprisoning
war I'm not sure why they removed the
horse because we do see Ganondorf
leading his army into combat on
Horseback in one of the memories or I
guess a unicorn from the looks of it the
shot that comes the closest to the one
in the teaser is the one right here so
we'll just go with that one next up we
have a top down view of the energy
spiral and this sequence does not show
up in the game whatsoever so once again
we're going to have to resort to the
free cam for this one the only notable
difference is the way the particles look
between the two versions in the teaser
they are much more plentiful detailed
and feature some of that same movement
seen in the opening shot but since we
never actually get close to the spiral
during gameplay I understand why they
toned it down again probably for the
sake of performance we we then move on
to what is probably the shot with the
highest amount of cut content in the
entire teaser and first and foremost is
of course Zelda's unusual animal Mount
while the creature itself did make it
into the game as a sort of side quest
and lore Exposition its use as a mode of
Transport below hyu Castle has been
completely removed while I do think it's
a shame because it did look pretty
awesome in the teaser I do understand
why they changed it the implementation
just doesn't work anymore knowing what
we know now about the area below the
castle during the opening segment
Lincoln's Z are essentially already in
the final stretch of their little cave
Expedition so most of their Journey
happens offscreen that said the game
does give us a pretty good idea of the
type of secret passages rooms and
corridors that exist below the castle
and well it's not exactly practical for
a rhino sized animal I mean good luck
trying to get this Beast through these
narrow doorways or up and down these
staircases the second and in my opinion
biggest change in this shot and the
teaser as a whole for that matter is the
architecture now I'm going to Stand My
Ground on this and say I I think it was
a mistake to change the zonai
architecture from that which we were
familiar with to whatever this is
supposed to be I mean what was so wrong
with the original zonai stonework that
they felt compelled to change the one
thing we knew about them and it's not
like the original architecture was redon
or over written either it still exists
alongside the new stonework don't get me
wrong it's not that I have a problem
with adding new previously unseen zonai
architecture to the mix in fact the
teaser is filled with both familiar
structures we know from the previous
game as well as brand new ones like this
wall for example or that impressive
looking Bridge or the amazing entrance
we get a brief glimpse of but at least
these were modeled after the same style
seen in breath the wild unlike the new
stonework which may as well have come
from a completely different race
altogether and you know maybe that's
what they were going for but I still
think having two completely different
architectural Styles attributed to the
same race is just needlessly confusing
and makes the whole Zoni lore feel a bit
inconsistent but that's just my opinion
of course also there's a rat there but
we'll talk about that shortly it goes
without saying that I can't can't really
make a faithful Recreation of this
sequence at least not right now there's
just too many elements missing so until
someone creates a mod that allows you to
spawn the animal down here and make it
ridable we'll just have to De with a
more boring shot of Lin and Zelda
traversing on foot instead next we have
a shot of Link and Zelda overlooking the
imprisoning chamber and this one matches
pretty well with the shot I mentioned
earlier which is the moment right before
you trigger The Awakening cut scene the
only thing that doesn't match is the
camera movement which in the teaser is
slowly panning upwards on top of that
there's also a dialogue box that gets in
the way so once again freak C we then
transition to a shot of Link Zelda and
the packing animal standing close to a
body of water and there's a very similar
looking area in the game as well in fact
it's the very first room you enter once
you're in control of link it even has a
name the Forgotten spring there's not
that much going on in this room except
for a brief cut scene that triggers
halfway across but that cut scene
doesn't feature a camera angle like the
one in the teaser in other words another
candidate for the free cam next we have
our little rodent friend over here who
was definitely done dirty they just
completely rode him out of the story for
no discernable reason in fact there's
not even any rats in the game at all
same goes for cats but that's besides
the point anyway rest in peace my friend
your sacrifice to the malice will not be
forgotten we then cut to the impressive
looking zonai bridge I mentioned earlier
in the teaser it seems to serve as a
sort of bottleneck that forces Lincoln
Zelda to leave the animal behind but
since there is no animal in the final
game the sequence was scrapped
altogether the that said there is still
a remnant of this bridge present in the
game a little callback if you will when
you explore this area later on you'll
come across the remains of a bridge
which has seemingly collapsed not only
that but this room leads straight into
the stairway where the game started so
even though this part of Lincoln Zelda's
Journey isn't shown in game we can at
least deduce that they did in fact cross
this bridge moments before the opening
segment it even has some green glowing
spots on the outer walls very similar to
those giant luminous crystals seen in
the teaser shot granted it doesn't look
nearly as impressive as it did in the
teaser but at least there's something
left in the game that calls back to it
which I can appreciate it's also worth
noting that the bridge and chamber as we
see it here probably looked very
different when Link and Zelda crossed it
other parts of this Cave System show
that when the castle rose up a lot of
the architecture in this area was
heavily damaged and covered in Gloom
staircases crumbled giant pillars were
knocked over the whole place basically
fell apart so we can assume that the
bridge was also still intact before this
happened unfortunately we aren't able to
see these sections in their original
more pristine State because they don't
exist the entire intro takes place in
its own self-contained map essentially a
duplicate of the area we get to explore
later during the opening segment the
game doesn't allow you to backtrack to
where you came from or more specifically
Zelda doesn't allow it because well as
you can see there's nothing there the
map just stops so for this one I decided
to just show a part of the bridge that's
still intact since we don't have a whole
lot to work with next up we see Zelda
investigating something with her torch
follow followed by her surprised
reaction there's a couple of different
moments I could use for this one since
Zelda does quite a bit of detective work
during the intro there's the Zone I text
on a pillar that's been toppled over a
carving of a dragon she investigates and
takes pictures of a zonai statue which
also draws her attention for a while and
of course we have the mural which gets
the biggest reaction out of her by far
in my original video about the 2019
teaser I proposed that the closeup of
the torch and wall paintings and the
shot of zela's reaction are probably
sequential and I still suspect that
that's what they were going for so since
we previously used this shot for the
closeup I think it's only fitting that
we use a shot from that same cut scene
coming up we have four shots in quick
succession which I'm basically going to
tackle as one it starts with an
establishing shot of Ganondorf and the
green energy followed up by three brief
close-ups two of Ganondorf and one of
ru's arm for the first shot there are
two moments in the Awakening cut scene
that convey a somewhat similar Vibe
however one has linoln Zelda in the
frame so that doesn't work and the other
is a little too close compared to the
teaser not only that but but the upward
camera movement is missing in both this
may seem like nitpicks and it's probably
an editor thing but the way the sequence
plays out in the teaser was done very
deliberately the first shot is just far
enough away that the identity of the
corpse is still a bit difficult to
determine with 100% certainty especially
on a first viewing this is then
purposely followed up by some brief
close-ups that slowly reveal more and
more information you know the clothing
the gudo jewelry the mysterious hand and
the malice seeping through the holes in
his chest the only thing it doesn't show
is andor's face that part is safe for
later it's basically meant to build
tension and a sense of mystery for the
viewer and to tie the whole thing
together into one continuous sequence
all four shots feature that same upward
camera movement in other words it's time
for some more of that sweet delicious
free cam we follow up with a full body
shot of Ganondorf which is not only very
brief but has a lot of shaky cam
indicating some sort of earthquake I'm
pretty sure this is an early depiction
of the moment the cave starts collapsing
which has been changed quite a bit in
the actual game game here the seal has
already been broken at that point and
ru's arm is no longer latched onto
ganondorf's chest but in the teaser this
isn't the case I think the Zelda team
knew from the get-go that they wanted
Ganondorf to do something to trigger the
collapse but they hadn't worked out the
exact sequence of events yet which is
something we'll see a lot more of moving
forward where the general idea is
already there but the details behind how
exactly this will play out clearly
hadn't been decided yet now instead of
using my own camera angle and
artificially adding shaky cam in post I
think we can just use this shot instead
since it's basically conveying the same
thing from this moment on things
continue to move at a very rapid Pace
with most shots only lasting a second or
less we start with Link's arm absorbing
the green energy and I think this is
another example of an early preconceived
idea that hadn't been worked out yet but
was still included as a sort of hint for
the audience in this case as a hint to
Link's new powers the most telling part
is the fact that Link's arm looks
completely fine no Burns no tissue
damage from the Gloom attack and no
bracelet either so maybe the Gloom
attack simply wasn't conceptualized yet
and instead they just showed some green
energy going into Link's right arm
without further context for the final
game they seem to have split this moment
up into two separate events one where
link gets the Gloom treatment and one
where the green energy settles into his
arm during the aftermath as for which
shot to use for my own teaser I'm
leaning more towards the Gloom attack
because at least here link is not only
conscious but he's standing in almost
the exact same pose clutching his right
arm with his left so let's go with that
one we then cut to ganondorf's Gloom
hitting the ceiling and this one is
pretty straightforward I already
mentioned that the design of the ceiling
has been changed and there's a very
similar sequence in The Awakening cut
scene we can use so yeah that's about it
next up is a very short closeup of link
and Zelda's hands reaching out to each
other in my video from 2020 I proposed
that this was depicting Link's failed
attempt to reach out and catch Zelda
right as she's about to fall into the
abyss however some people had issues
with that because according to them
there aren't any Gloom particles visible
in this sh sh and so they opted that
this was a completely unrelated sequence
that had nothing to do with Zelda's fall
one example given was a sequence where
link helped Zelda climb up a ledge or
something even back then I didn't agree
with this because it's pretty clear that
most of the Gloom particles reside above
the ledge not below it plus it's a
closeup so who's to say there aren't any
particles right outside the frame
naturally the shot we see here didn't
even make it into the game so we'll
probably never know for sure what it was
supposed to depict but I'm going to
stick to my guns and say that this is
most likely a precursor to this moment
moving on we have a brief shot of that
gorgeous looking entrance which I still
think was supposed to be the entrance to
the imprisoning chamber or at the very
least the final stairway or hallway
leading into it I think this design was
perfect especially with that big boar
statue on top of the door it just
screams ganon's Lair I love it but as
mentioned before sadly it didn't make it
in and what we got instead was not up to
par in my opinion the actual Doorway to
the imprisoning chamber is very Bland
and uninteresting it looks just like
like any other doorway the only entrance
in this general area that looks somewhat
impressive is the other doorway inside
the mural chamber which I guess is the
next best thing I can use for my own
teaser of course it doesn't lead to the
imprisoning chamber in fact it leads in
the opposite direction but I mean I
don't exactly have a whole lot of
options next we have a shot of raru
saving link mid-fall and this one is
quite similar to what we see in the
Awakening cut scene the only real
difference is that we don't visually see
raru grabbing on to link like we see it
in the teaser here this happens just
just out of frame and in the next shot
link is already dangling in the air but
we can still use this part and have it
make sense next in line we have another
sequence that was completely removed
that brief flash on the wall showing the
moment of ganondorf's imprisonment and
honestly I don't really have a problem
with its removal it worked for the
teaser because at the time we didn't
know who the green arm belonged to but
in the actual game we learn almost
immediately who sealed him away and we
even get to see it happen in a later
memory I do still want to include
something in its place so for this one
I'll just show a brief flash of that
memory the next two shots are easy since
we have an almost identical sequence in
the final game a closeup of the floor
crumbling below Zelda's feet followed by
her going over the edge while the camera
angles are not one for one it is in
essence still the same event just from a
different point of view the same cannot
be said about the next two shots though
there's not really anything in the game
that matches these two moments
ganondorf's hand is the first thing that
starts moving but when this happens
Zelda is not in the frame initially I
wanted to just show a close-up of
ganondorf's hand using the free cam but
he doesn't move until the Awakening cut
scene and this cut scene is pre-rendered
meaning I have zero control over the
camera during this part that twitching
movement the hand makes is kind of the
main focal point since it signifies
ganondorf's first signs of life you know
before all hell breaks loose so the most
logical option is to just show a closeup
of the hand moving luckily I do have
this entire cutscene upscale to 4K
courtesy of Conrad from the Commonwealth
realm this means I can easily zoom in on
ganondorf's right hand without losing
too much image quality Zelda not being
in the frame is not that big of a deal
in fact one difference I haven't
mentioned up until now is that
originally it was link who was holding
the torch throughout the entire
confrontation with Ganondorf on the
altar from the moment they approached
the corpse the Zelda's fall every shot
inside the imprisoning chamber except
for this one so it's always been a bit
of a strange outlier especially
considering that in the very next shot
which I assume was supposed to take
place shortly after she doesn't have the
torch anymore in the finalized cut scene
they corrected this now Zelda the one
holding it from beginning to end freeing
up Link's hands to use the mastera sword
which I'm pretty sure is the reason why
they changed it to begin with as for
Zelda's turnaround shot I was always
under the impression that this took
place right before she falls but this
never happens during the cut scene at no
point does she ever turn around like
that and she has no reason to since
she's always facing in the direction of
Ganondorf she doesn't try to run back
across the bridge or anything like that
so it only makes sense that they would
remove the shot altogether it's a bit of
a shame because it did mirror a moment
from acarina time but oh well now there
are plenty of shots of Zelda reacting to
ganador presence and action so we'll
just use one of these moments as a
replacement next we have the one shot
that has remained virtually unchanged
for the final build and for good reason
because it was such an iconic part of
the teaser there is a very slight
difference in the animation but it's
negligible at best and besides that the
only notable change is the lighting
which is a little darker compared to the
2019 shot oh and I guess they found the
original neck cracking sound effect a
little too
Island and finally we conclude with the
rising hyu Castle now obviously the shot
we see here is not represented in the
finished game in fact in the teaser we
don't even got to see what really
happens to the castle hence why there
were so many theories about the castle
taking off into space or growing legs
and marching across Hyrule like a
certain Studio gibli Movie in the game
we never get an establishing shot of
Hyrule like this when the castle starts
to move instead the event is shown up
close from multiple angles only after
it's already suspended do we get a wide
shot of the castle from a distance which
is still a lot closer than the one from
the teaser again the cut scene from the
game is pre-rendered so there's no way
for me to show this event happening from
a distance as such I made a custom shot
of the castle as seen from the great
Plateau which then transitions into the
actual in-game cut scene when the castle
starts to rise up not exactly accurate
but it's serviceable and with that we
have reached the end of the 2019 teaser
I'll accept the announcement at the very
end but I got that one covered as well
no worries now before I showcase the new
and well probably not improved version
of the teaser let me quickly address one
final change which I kind of forgot
about while writing the script so I'm
just going to do it now the secret
Stones aka the dumbest name for a
magical artifact since the hoe of
Destruction I think it's safe to say
that the stones probably weren't thought
of yet when they made the teaser back in
2019 some may think that they were and
Nintendo was simply keeping the secret
Stones well a secret but given the track
record of all the other shots that were
drastically changed or outright removed
I think the more logical option is that
the idea simply didn't exist yet which
is why in 2019 ganondorf's head Jewel
was still a regular gemstone like the
one he had in previous titles and why
ru's arm also didn't feature a secret
Stone yet I'm aware that Nintendo
sometimes leav stuff out of their
promotional material to keep certain
plot points on the Ws but given how
early this teaser was presented and how
long the game ended up being in
development I think we can chalk this up
to a concept that came into existence
later down the line in general I think
that during the teasers creation the
Zelda team only had a very rough idea of
where they wanted to take this story as
well as the other content they wanted to
include things like the sky islands and
the depths may have already been on the
table but how exactly they would look
and function was probably still up for
consideration anyway I think it's time
to showcase the final result do keep in
mind that I am using the original audio
so sometimes the sound effects may not
always align perfectly with what's
happening on screen there's not really
much I can do about that so ladies and G
gentlemen here is the 2019 teaser
recreated in tears of the kingdom and a
little bit of After
[Music]
Effects
I'm going
[Music]
to
so what do you think did I manage to
capture the magic of the original or did
I completely butcher it beyond
recognition be sure to let me know down
in the comments also if you enjoyed this
video in general let me know that as
well and you know maybe I can do more of
these types of videos in the future
after all we have a bunch more footage
to work with as well as the patents
Nintendo issued and the concept art from
the art book I want to give a
well-deserved shout out to Max Last
Breath who is single-handedly
responsible for creating the amazing
free cam I used for this video as well
as gossip Guist who not only instigated
the free cam project but was also kind
enough to keep me up to date on the prog
ress and gave me early access to it
suffice to say this video would not have
been possible without them finally a big
shout out to Claire hegard Aron and the
rest of my amazing patreons and channel
members your support continues to make
this channel possible thank you for
watching that is all for now and I hope
to see you all next
[Music]
time
[Applause]
[Music]
a